The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocs.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Today we
have plenty to do.
We really begin
in all generality
the addition of
angular momentum.
But we will do it in the set
up of a physical problem.
The problem of
computing the spin
orbit interactions of
electrons with the nucleus.
So this is a rather interesting
and complicated interaction.
So we'll spend a
little time telling you
about the physics
of this interaction.
And then once the
physics is clear,
it will become
more obvious why we
have to do these mathematical
contortions of adding angular
momentum in order to solve
this physical problem.
So it's a sophisticated problem
that requires several steps.
The first step is
something that is
a result in perturbation theory.
Feynman Hellman Theorem
of perturbation theory.
And that's where we begin.
So it's called Feynman
Hellman Theorem.
It's a very simple result.
Theorem.
And we'll need it in
order to understand
how a small perturbation
to the Hamiltonian
changes the energy spectrum.
So we have H of lambda be a
Hamiltonian with a parameter
in lambda.
Lambda.
And psi n of lambda
being normalized energy
eigenstate with
energy, En of lambda.
So that's the whole
assumption of the theorem.
We have a Hamiltonian.
It depends on some parameter
that we're going to vary.
And suppose we consider now an
eigenstate of this Hamiltonian
that depends on lambda,
so the eigenstate also
depends on lambda.
And it has an
energy, En of lambda.
So the purpose of
this theorem is
to relate these
various quantities.
And the claim is that
the rate of change
of the energy with
respect to lambda
can be computed pretty much by
evaluating the rate of change
of the Hamiltonian on
the relevant states.
So that's the claim.
And it's a pretty nice result.
It's useful in
many circumstances.
And for us will be a way to
discuss a little perturbation
theory.
Perturbation theory is the
subject of 806 in all details.
And it's a very
sophisticated subject.
Even today we were going
to be finding that it's not
all that easy to carry it out.
So how does this begin?
Well, proof.
You begin by saying
that En of lambda
is the energy eigenstate,
is nothing else
but psi n of lambda.
H of lambda.
Psi n of lambda.
And the reason is, of
course, that H and psi n
is En of lambda times
psi n of lambda.
And this is a number goes out.
And the inner product
of this things
is 1, because the
state is normalized.
So this is a good
starting point.
And the funny thing that you see
already is that, in some sense,
you just get the
middle term when
you take the derivative
with respect to lambda.
You don't get anything
from these two.
And it's simple in fact.
So let me just do it.
V, En, V lambda
would be the term
that Feynman and Hellman gave.
V, H, V lambda, psi n of lambda.
Plus one term in which we
differentiate this one.
V, d lambda of the
state psi n of lambda.
Times H of lambda,
psi n of lambda.
Plus the other term in which
you differentiate the ket.
So psi n of lambda, H of lambda,
d, d lambda of psi n of lambda.
And the reason these
terms are going to vanish
is that you can now act
with H again on psi n.
H is supposed to be Hermitian,
so it can act on the left.
And therefore, these two
terms give you En of lambda,
times d d lambda of psi n of
lambda-- psi n of lambda--
plus the other term, which
would be psi n of lambda,
the bra times the
derivative of the ket.
But this is nothing
else than the derivative
of the inner product.
In the inner product
to differentiate--
the inner product
differentiates the bra,
it differentiates the ket.
And do it.
And this thing is equal to
1, because it's normalized.
So this is 0.
End of proof.
These two terms vanish.
And the result holds.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How do you
know it stays normalized
when you vary lambda?
PROFESSOR: It's an assumption.
The state is normalized
for all values of n.
So if you have a state
that you've constructed,
that is normalized, you
can have this result.
So it's an assumption.
You have to keep the
state normalized.
Now this is a baby version
of perturbation theory.
It's a result I think that
Feynman did as an undergrad.
And as you can see,
it's very simple.
Calling it a theorem
is a little too much.
But still, the fact
is that it's useful.
And so we'll just
go ahead and use it.
Now I want to rewrite
it in another way.
So, suppose you have
a Hamiltonian, H,
which has a term
H0, plus lambda, H1.
So, the parameter lambda, H of
lambda, is given in this way.
And that's a
reasonable H of lambda.
Sometimes, this could be
written as H0 plus something
that we will call the
change in the Hamiltonian.
And we usually think
of it as a small thing.
So what do we have
from this theorem?
From this here we would
have the d, En, d lambda
is equal to psi n of
lambda, H1, psi n of lambda.
Now, we can be
particularly interested
in the evaluation of this
thing at lambda equals 0.
So what is d En of lambda?
d lambda at lambda equals
0 would be psi n at zero,
H1, psi n at 0.
And therefore, you would say
that the En of lambda energies
would be the energies
at 0, plus lambda, d En
of lambda, d lambda
at lambda equals 0,
plus order lambda squared.
I'm doing just the
Taylor expansion
of En's of lambda
from lambda equals 0.
So this thing tells you that
En of lambda is equal En of 0,
plus-- this derivative you can
write it as psi n, lambda, H1,
psi n, all at 0.
Like that.
Plus order lambda squared.
So in this step, I just use the
evaluation that we did here.
I substituted that
and put the lambda in.
So that I recognize now that En
of lambda is equal to En of 0,
plus psi n of 0-- and I can
write this as delta H-- psi
n of 0, plus order
delta H squared.
It's nice to write it this
way, because you appreciate
more the power of the theorem.
The theorem here doesn't assume
which value of lambda you have.
And you have to have
normalized eigenstates.
And you wonder what is
it helping you with,
if finding the states for every
value of lambda is complicated.
Well, it certainly
helps you to figure out
how the energy of the state
varies by a simple calculation.
Suppose you know the states
of the simple Hamiltonian.
Those are the psi's, n, 0.
So if you have the
psi n 0 over here,
you can do the following step.
If you want to figure out
how it's energy has varied,
use this formula in which
you compute the expectation
value of the change in the
Hamiltonian on that state.
And that is the first correction
to the energy of the state.
So you have this state.
You compute the
expectation value
of the extra piece
in the Hamiltonian.
And that's the
correction to the energy.
It's a little more
complicated of course
to compute the
correction to the state.
But that's a subject
of perturbation theory.
And that's not what we
care about right now.
So the reason we're doing this
is because actually whatever
we're going to have
with spin orbit coupling
represents an addition
to the hydrogen
Hamiltonian of a new term.
Therefore, you want to know what
happens to the energy levels.
And the best thing
to think about them
is to-- if you know the
energy levels of this one,
well, a formula of
this type can let
you know what happens
to the energy levels
after the perturbation.
There will be an
extra complication
in that the energy levels
that we're going to deal with
are going to be degenerate.
But let's wait for that
complication until it appears.
So any questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So I would
imagine that this
would work just
as well for time.
Because time [INAUDIBLE] a
parameter in quantum mechanics.
So [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Time dependent
perturbation theory
is a bit more complicated.
I'd rather not get into it now.
So let's leave it here, in
which we don't have time.
And the Schrodinger
equation is something
like H psi equal [INAUDIBLE]
psi, that's all we care.
And leave it for that moment.
Other questions?
OK.
So let's proceed with
addition of angular momentum.
So first, let me give you
the fundamental result
of addition of angular momentum.
It's a little abstract,
but it's what we really
mean by addition of
angular momentum.
Of angular momentum.
And the main result
is the following.
Suppose you have a set
of operators, J, i,
1, that have the algebra
of angular momentum.
Of angular momentum.
Which is to say
Ji1, JJ1, is equal
i, h bar, epsilon iJK, JK1.
And this algebra is realized
on some state space.
On some vector space, V1.
And suppose you have
another operator,
J-- set of operators actually.
Ji2, which have the algebra
of angular momentum.
I will not write that.
On some V2.
OK.
Angular momentum,
some sets of states.
Angular momentum on some
other set of states.
Here comes the thing.
There is a new angular
momentum, which
is the sum Ji defined
as Ji1, added with Ji2.
Now, soon enough you will
just write Ji1, plus Ji2.
But let me be a little
more careful now.
This sum is Ji1,
plus 1, tensor Ji2.
So i is the same index.
But here, we're
having this operator
that we're being defined
that we call it the sum.
Now how do you sum two operators
that act in different spaces?
Well, the only thing
that you can actually do
is sum them in the
tensor product.
So the claim is that this is an
angular momentum in V1 tensor
V2.
That is an operator.
You see, you have to sum them.
So you have to create a
space where both can act,
and you can sum them.
You cannot sum a thing, an
operator that acts on one
vector space to an operator that
acts on another vector space.
You have to create one
vector space where both act.
And then you can define
the sum of the operators.
Sum of operators
is a simple thing.
So you form the tensor product.
In here, this
operator gets upgraded
in this way, in which in the
tensor product it has a 1
for the second input.
This one gets
upgrade to this way.
And this is the sum.
So this is a claim--
this is a definition.
And this is a claim.
So this has to be proven.
So let me prove it.
Ji, JJ.
I compute this commutator.
So I don't have to
do the following.
I have to do Ji1, tensor
1, plus 1 tensor Ji2.
And then the JJ would be JJ1,
tensor 1, plus 1, tensor JJ2.
Have to compute this commutator.
Now, an important
fact about this
result that I'm not
trying to generalize,
if you had put a minus
here, it wouldn't work out.
If you would have put a 2
If you would have put a 1/2
here, it won't work out.
This is pretty much
the only way you
can have two angular momenta,
and create a third angular
momentum.
So look at this.
It looks like we're going
to have to work hard,
but that's not true.
Consider this commutator.
The commutator of this
term with this term.
That's 0 actually.
Because if you multiply them
in this order, this times that,
you get Ji1 times Ji2,
because the ones do nothing.
You multiply them in
the reverse order,
you get again, Ji1 times Ji2.
This is to say that the
operators that originally lived
in the different
vector spaces commute.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Since the cross
terms between those two
are 0-- like you just said,
the cross terms are 0.
And if you put a minus sign
in there, it will cancel.
But when you do
the multiplications
with the second ones, why can't
you put a minus sign in there?
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: In the whole thing?
In this definition,
a minus sign?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Well, here
if I put a minus--
it's like I'm going to
prove that this works.
So if-- I'm going to
get an angular momentum.
If I put a minus sign
to angular momentum,
I ruin the algebra here.
I put a minus minus, it cancels.
But then I get a
minus sign here.
So I cannot really
even change a sign.
So any way, these are operators
acting on different spaces.
They commute.
It's clear they commute.
You just multiply
them, and see that.
These one's commute as well.
The only ones that don't
commute are this with this.
And that with that.
So let me just write them.
Ji1, tensor 1,
with JJ1, tensor 1.
Plus this one, 1 tensor
Ji2, 1 tensor JJ2.
OK, next step is to
realize that actually
the 1 is a spectator here.
Therefore, this
commutator is nothing
but the commutator Ji1
with JJ1, tensor 1.
You can do it.
If you prefer to
write it, write it.
This product is Ji
times JJ, tensor 1.
And the other product
is JJ, Ji, tensor 1.
So the tensor 1 factors out.
Here the tensor 1
also factors out.
And you get an honest
commutator, Ji2, JJ2.
So one last step.
This is i, h bar, epsilon, iJK.
I'll put a big parentheses.
JK1, tensor 1,
for the first one.
Because J1 forms an
angular momentum algebra.
And here, 1 tensor JK2.
And this thing is i,
h bar, epsilon, iJK.
The total angular
momentum, K. And you've
shown the algebra works out.
Now most people after
a little practice,
they just say, oh, Ji is
J1 plus J2, J1 plus J2.
J1 and J2 don't commute.
J2 and J1-- I'm sorry.
J1 and J2 commute.
J2 and J1 commute.
Therefore you get
this 2, like that.
And this gives you--
J1 and J1 gives you J1.
J2 and J2 gives you J2,
so the sum works out.
So most people after
a little practice
just don't put all
these tensor things.
But at the beginning it's
nice to just make sure
that you understand what
these tensor things do.
All right.
So that's our main
theorem-- that you
start with one angular
momentum on a state space.
Another angular momentum that
has nothing to do perhaps
with the first on
another vector space.
And on the tensor product you
have another angular momentum,
which is the sum.
All right.
So now, we do spin
orbit coupling
to try to apply these ideas.
So for spin orbit coupling, we
will consider the hydrogen atom
coupling.
And the new term in the
Hamiltonian, mu dot B.
The kind of term that we've
done so much in this semester.
We've looked over magnetic ones.
So which magnetic
moment at which B?
There was no B in
the hydrogen atom.
Well, there's no
B to begin with.
But here is one where you can
think there is a B. First,
this will be the
electron dipole moment.
Magnetic dipole moment.
So we have a formula for it.
The formula for it is the mu of
the electron is minus E over m,
times the spin of the electron.
And I actually will use a
little different formula
that is valued in
Gaussian units.
ge over mC, S, in
And g is the g factor of
the electron, which is 2.
I'm sorry.
There's a 2 here.
OK.
So look what I've written.
I don't want to distract
you with this too much.
But you know that the magnetic
dipole of the electron
is given by this quantity.
Now, you could put a
2 up, and a 2 down.
And that's why people
actually classically
there seems to be a 2 down.
But there's a 2 up, because
it's an effect of the electron.
And you have this formula.
The only thing I've
added in that formula
is a factor of C that is
because of Gaussian units.
And it allows you to estimate
terms a little more easily.
So that's the mu
of the electron.
But the electron apparently
would feel no magnetic field.
You didn't put an
external magnetic field.
Except that here
you go in this way
of thinking-- you think
suppose you are the electron.
You see a proton, which is
a nucleus going around you.
And a proton going around you
is a current going around you.
It generates a magnetic field.
And therefore, you
see a magnetic field
created by the proton
going around you.
So there is a magnetic field.
And there's a magnetic
field experienced
by the electron--
felt by electron.
So you can think of
this, the electron.
Here is the proton
with the plus charge,
and here's the electron.
And the electron is
going around the proton.
Now, from the viewpoint
of the electron,
the proton is going around him.
So here is the proton.
Here is the electron
going like that.
From the viewpoint
of the electron,
the proton is going like this.
Also, from the viewpoint
of the electron,
the proton would be
going in this direction
and creating a
magnetic field up.
And the magnetic field
up corresponds actually
to the idea that the angular
momentum of the electron
is also up-- L of the
electron is also up.
So the whole point
of this thing is
that somehow this magnetic field
is proportional to the angular
momentum.
And then, L will come here.
And here, you have
S. So you have
L dot S. That's the
fine structure coupling.
Now let me do a little
of this so that we just
get a bit more feeling,
although it's unfortunately
a somewhat frustrating exercise.
So let me tell you
what's going on.
So consider the electron.
At some point, look at
it and draw a plane.
So the electron-- let's
assume it's going down.
Here is the proton.
It's going around in circles.
So here, it's going down.
The electron is going down.
Electron, its velocity of
the electron is going down.
The proton is over here.
And the electron is
going around like that.
The proton would produce an
electric field of this form.
Now, in relativity, the
electric and magnetic fields
seen by different
observers are different.
So there is this electric
field that we see.
We sit here, and we
see in our rest frame
this proton creates
an electric field.
And then, from the
viewpoint of the electron,
the electron is moving.
And there is an electric field.
But whenever you are moving
inside an electric field,
you also see a magnetic field
generated by the motion,
by relativistic effects.
The magnetic field
that you see is roughly
given to first order in
relativity by V cross E over c.
So V cross E, VE
V cross E over c
up-- change sign
because of this.
And the magnetic
field consistently,
as we would expect,
goes in this direction.
So it's consistent
with the picture
that we developed that if you
were the electron, the proton,
would be going around
in circles like that
and the magnetic
field would be up.
Now here I can change the sign
by doing E cross V over c.
So this is the magnetic
field seen by the electron.
OK, so we need a little more
work on that magnetic field
by calculating the
electric field.
Now, what is the electric field?
Well, the scalar potential
for the hydrogen atom,
we write it as minus
e squared over r.
It's actually not quite
the scalar potential.
But it is the potential energy.
It has one factor of e more than
what the scalar potential is.
Remember, the scalar
potential in electromagnetism
is charge divided by r.
So it has one factor of e more.
What is the derivative
of this potential?
With respect to r, it's
e squared over r squared.
So the electric field goes
like e over r squared.
So the electric field is
equal to dV dr divided by e.
That's the magnitude
of the electric field.
And its direction is radial from
the viewpoint of the proton.
The electric field is here.
So this can be written
as r vector divided by r.
Therefore, the magnetic field
will-- [INAUDIBLE] this.
The magnetic field
now can be calculated.
And we'll see what
we claimed was
the relation with
angular momentum.
Because B prime
is now E cross V.
So you have 1 over
ec 1 over r dV dr.
I've taken care of this.
And now I just have
r cross V. Well,
r cross V is your angular
momentum if you had p here.
So we borrow a factor of
the mass of the electron,
ecm 1 over r dV dr
L, L of the electron.
p equals mv.
So we have a nice formula
for B. And then, we
can go and calculate delta
H. Delta H would then
be minus mu dot B. And that
would be ge over 2mc spin
dot L-- mu was given here--
S dot L 1 over r dV dr.
And that is the split
spin orbit interaction.
Now, the downside
of this derivation
is that it has a
relativistic error.
There's a phenomenon
called Thomas precession
that affects this result.
We didn't waste our time.
The true result is that you
must subtract from this g 1.
So g must really be
replaced by g minus 1.
Since g is approximately
2 for the electron,
the true result is
really 1/2 of this thing.
So this should not
be in parentheses,
but true result is this.
And the mistake that is done
in calculating this spin orbit
coupling is that this
spin orbit coupling
affects precession rates.
All these interactions
of magnetic dipoles
with magnetic fields
affect precession rates.
And you have to be a
little more careful here
that the system where you've
worked, the electron rest frame
is not quite an inertial system.
Because it's doing
circular motion.
So there's an extra correction
that has to be done.
Thomas precession or Thomas
correction it's called.
And it would be a
detour of about one hour
in special relativity
to do it right.
So Griffiths doesn't do it.
I don't think Shankar does it.
Pretty much graduate
books do it.
So we will not try to do better.
I mentioned that
fact that this really
should be reduced to
one half of its value.
And it's an interesting
system to analyze.
So Thomas precession is
that relativistic correction
to precession rates when the
object that is precessing
is in an accelerated frame.
And any rotating
frame is accelerated.
So this result needs correction.
OK, but let's take this result
as it is-- instead of g,
g minus 1.
Let's not worry
too much about it.
And let's just estimate
how big this effect is.
It's the last thing I want
to do as a way of motivating
this subject.
So delta H is this.
Let's estimate it.
Now for estimates, a couple of
things are useful to remember,
that Bohr radius is h
squared over me squared.
We did that last time.
And there's this constant
that is very useful,
the fine structure constant,
which is e squared over hc.
And it's about 1 over 137.
And it helps you estimate
all kinds of things.
Because it's a rather
complicated number to evaluate,
you need all kinds of
units and things like that.
So the charge of the electron
divided by hc being 1 over 137
is quite nice.
So let's estimate
delta H. Well, g
we won't worry-- 2,
1, doesn't matter.
e mc-- so far, that
is kind of simple.
Then we have S dot L. Well,
how do I estimate S dot L?
I don't do too much.
S spin is multiples of h bar.
L for an atomic state will be
1, 2, 3, so multiples of h bar.
So h bar squared,
that's it for S dot L.
1 over r is 1 over r.
dV dr is e squared
over r squared.
And that's it.
But here, instead of r, I
should put the typical length
of the hydrogen
atom, which is a0.
So what do I get?
I'm sorry, I made
a mistake here.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it's up there.
PROFESSOR: Oh, I
made a mistake here
in that I didn't put
this factor, 1 over ecm.
So the e cancels.
And this is the result
here-- g over 2m
squared c squared S dot L 1 over
r dV dr. So let me start again.
1 over m squared c squared h
bar squared 1 over r dV dr--
that much I got right.
So this is roughly
1 over [INAUDIBLE]
of the electron
squared c squared e
squared over a0 cubed
h squared-- still quite
messy, but not that terrible.
So in order to get an
idea of how big this is,
the ground state energy
of the hydrogen atom
was e squared over 2a0.
So let's divide delta H over
the ground state energy.
And that's how much?
Well, we have all this
quantity, 1 over m
squared c squared e
squared a0 cubed h squared.
And now, we must divide by
e squared over a0 like this.
Well, the e squareds cancel.
And we get h squared over m
squared c squared a0 squared.
You need to know what a0 is.
Let's just boil it down
to the simplest thing,
so h squared m
squared c squared.
a0 squared would be h to
the fourth m squared e
to the fourth.
So this is actually e
to the fourth over h
squared c squared, or e squared
over hc squared, which is alpha
squared.
Whew-- lots of work to
get something very nice.
The ratio of the spin orbit
coupling to the ground state
energy is 1 over alpha squared.
It's alpha squared, which
is 1 over 137 squared.
So it's a pretty small thing.
It's about 1 over 19,000.
So when this is called fine
structure of the hydrogen atom,
it means that it's in
the level in your page
that you use a few inches
to plot the 13.6 electron
volts-- well, you're talking
about 20,000 times smaller,
something that you don't see.
But of course, it's a
pretty important thing.
So all in all, in the
conventions of-- this
is done in Gaussian units.
In SI units, which is
what Griffiths uses,
delta H is e squared over
8 pi epsilon 0 1 over m
squared c squared r cubed S
dot L. That's for reference.
This is Griffiths.
But this is correct as well.
This is the correct value.
This is the correct
value already taking
into account the
relativistic correction.
So here, you're supposed
to let g go to g minus 1.
So you can put the 1 there,
and it's pretty accurate.
All right, so what is
the physics question
we want to answer with
this spin orbit coupling?
So here it comes.
You have the hydrogen
atom spectrum.
And that spectrum you know.
At L equals 0, you
have one state here.
Then, that's n
equals 1, n equals 2.
You have one state here and
one state here at L equals 1.
Then n equals 3, they start
getting very close together.
n equals 4 is like that.
Let's consider if you want
to have spin orbit coupling,
we must have angular momentum.
And that's L. And therefore,
let's consider this state here.
l equals 1, n equals 1--
n equals 2, I'm sorry.
What happens to those
states, is the question.
First, how many states
do you have there
and how should
you think of them?
Well actually, we know that
an l equals 1 corresponds
to three states.
So you'd have lm
with l equals 1.
And then m can be
1, 0, or minus 1.
So you have three states.
But there's not
really three states.
Because the electron
can have spin.
So here it is, a tensor product
that appears in your face
because there is
more than angular
momentum to the electron.
There's spin.
And it's a totally different
vector space, the same particle
but another vector
space, the spin space.
So here, you have the possible
spins of the electron.
So that's another
angular momentum.
And well, you could have the
plus/minus states, for example.
So you have three states
here and two states here.
So this is really six
states, so six states
whose fate we would
like to understand
due to this spin orbit coupling.
So to use the language
of angular momentum,
instead of writing
plus/minus, you
could write Smz, if you will--
ms I will call, spin of s.
You have here spin of 1/2
and states 1/2 or minus 1/2.
This is the up.
When the z component of the spin
that we always call m-- m now
corresponds to the z
component of angular momentum.
So in general, even
for spin, we use m.
And we have that our two
spin states of the electron
are spin 1/2 particle with
plus spin in the z direction,
spin 1/2 particle with minus
spin in the z direction.
We usually never
put this 1/2 here.
But now you have here
really three states--
1, 1, 1, 0, 1, minus 1,
the first telling you
about the total
angular momentum.
Here, the total spin is 1/2.
But it happens to be
either up or down.
Here, the total
angular momentum is 1.
But it happens to be plus
1, 0, or minus 1 here.
So these are our six states.
You can combine this with this,
this with that, this with this,
this with that.
You make all the products.
And these are the six
states of the hydrogen
atom at this level.
And we wish to know
what happens to them.
Now, this correction is small.
So it fits our understanding
of the perturbation theory
of Feynman-Hellman
in which we try
to find the corrections
to these things.
Our difficulty now is a
little serious, however.
It's the fact that
Feynman-Hellman
assumed that you had a state.
And it was an eigenstate of
the corrected Hamiltonian
as you moved along.
And then, you could compute
how its energy changes.
Here, unfortunately, we have a
much more difficult situation.
These six states that
I'm not listing yet,
but I will list very soon,
are not obviously eigenstates
of delta H. In fact, they are
not eigenstates of delta H.
They're degenerate states,
six degenerate states,
that are not eigenstates
of delta H. Therefore,
I cannot use the Feynman-Hellman
theorem until I find what are
the combinations that
are eigenstates of this
perturbation.
So we are a little
bit in trouble.
Because we have a perturbation
for which these product
states-- we call them uncoupled
bases-- are not eigenstates.
Now, we've written this
operator a little naively.
What does this operator
really mean, S dot L?
In our tensor products,
it means S1 tensor L1.
Actually, I'll use
L dot S. I'll always
put the L information first and
the S information afterward.
So L dot S is clearly
an operator that
must be thought to act
on the tensor product.
Because both have to act.
S has to act and L has to act.
So it only lives in
the tensor product.
So what does it mean?
It means this-- S2 L2 plus S3
L3, or sum over i Si tensor Li.
So this is the kind of thing
that you need to understand--
how do you find for this
operator's eigenstates here?
So that is our difficulty.
And that's what
we have to solve.
We're going to solve it
in the next half hour.
So it's a complicated operator,
L dot S. But on the other hand,
we have to use our ideas
that we've learned already
about summing angular momenta.
What if I define
J to be L plus S,
which really means L
tensor 1 plus 1 tensor S?
So this is what I really
mean by this operator.
J, as we've demonstrated,
will be an angular momentum,
because this satisfies the
algebra of angular momentum
and this satisfies the
algebra of angular momentum.
So this thing satisfies the
And why do we look at that term?
Because of the following reason.
We can square it-- JiJi.
Now we would have to
square this thing.
How do you square this thing?
Well, there's two ways.
Naively-- L squared
plus L squared plus 2L
dot S-- basically correct.
But you can do it a
little more slowly.
If you square this term,
you get L squared tensor 1.
you get 1 tensor S squared.
But when you do
the mixed products,
you just must take the
i's here and the i's here
and multiply them.
So actually, you do get two i's,
the sum over i Li tensor Si.
This is sum over i.
This is J squared.
So basically, what I'm saying
is that J squared naively
is L squared plus S squared
plus our interaction
2L dot S defined property.
So L dot S is equal to 1/2
of J squared minus L squared
minus S squared.
And that tells you all kinds of
interesting things about L dot
S.
Basically, we can trade
L dot S for J squared,
L squared, and S squared.
L squared is very
simple, and S squared
is extremely simple as well.
Remember, L squared
commutes with any Li.
So L squared with
any Li is equal to 0.
S squared with any
Si is equal to 0.
And Li's and Si's commute.
They live in different worlds.
So L squared and Si's commute.
S squareds and Li's commute.
These things are
pretty nice and simple.
So let's think now
of our Hamiltonian
and what is happening to it.
Whenever we had
the hydrogen atom,
we had a set of commuting
observables H, L squared,
and Lz.
It's a complete set of
commuting observables.
Now, in the hydrogen
atom, you could add to it
S squared and Sz.
We didn't talk about
spin at the beginning,
because we just considered
a particle going
around the hydrogen atom.
But if you have spin, the
hydrogen atom Hamiltonian,
the original one, doesn't
involve spin in any way.
So certainly, Hamiltonian
commutes with spin,
with spin z.
L and S don't talk, so
this is the complete set
of commuting observables.
But what happens to this list?
This is our problem for
H0, the hydrogen atom,
plus delta H that
has the S dot L.
Well, what are complete set
of commuting observables?
This is a very
important question.
Because this is
what tells you how
you're going to try to
organize the spectrum.
So we could have H,
the total, H total.
And what else?
Well, can I still
have L squared here?
Can I include L squared and say
it commutes with the total H?
A little worrisome,
but actually,
you know that L squared commutes
with the original Hamiltonian.
Now, the question is
whether L squared commutes
with this extra piece.
Well, but L squared
commutes with any Li.
And it doesn't even talk
to S. So L squared is safe.
L squared we can keep.
OK, S squared-- can
we keep S squared?
Well, S squared was here.
So it commuted with the
Hamiltonian, and that was good.
S squared commutes with any
Si, and it doesn't talk to L.
So S squared can stay.
But that's not good enough.
We won't be able to solve
the problem with this still.
We need more.
How about Lz?
It was here, so
let's try our luck.
Any opinions on Lz--
can we keep it or not?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I don't think so.
Because in the J term, we
have Lx's and Ly's, which
don't commute with Lz.
PROFESSOR: Right,
it can't be kept.
Here, this term has SxLx
plus SyLy plus SzLz.
And Lz doesn't
commute with this one.
So no, you can't
keep Lz-- no good.
On the other hand, let's
think about J squared.
J squared is here.
And J squared commutes with
L squared and with S squared.
J squared, therefore, is--
well, let me say it this way.
Here is L dot S, which
is our extra interaction.
Here we have this thing.
I would like to say
on behalf of J squared
that we can include
it here, J squared,
because J squared is
really pretty much the same
as L dot S up to this L
squared and S squared.
But J squared commutes with
L squared and S squared.
I should probably
write it there.
J squared commutes
with L squared.
And J squared communicates with
S squared that we have here.
And moreover, we have over
here that J squared therefore
will commute, or it's
pretty much the same,
as L dot S. J squared
with L dot S would
be J squared times
this thing, which is 0.
So J squared commutes
with this term.
And it commutes with
the Hamiltonian,
your original
hydrogen Hamiltonian.
So J squared can be added here.
J square is a good
operator to have.
And now we can get one more
kind of free from here.
It's Jz.
Z
Because Jz commutes
with J squared.
Jz commutes with these things.
And Jz, which is a symmetry
of the original Hamiltonian,
also commutes with our new
interaction, the L dot S,
which is proportional
to J squared.
So you have to go
through this yourselves
probably even a little
more slowly than I've gone.
Just check that
everything that I'm
saying about whatever
commutes commutes.
So for example, when I say
that J squared commutes
with L dot S, it's
because I can put
instead of L dot S all of this.
And go slowly through this.
So this is actually the complete
set of committing observables.
And it's basically
saying to us, try
to diagonalize this thing
with total angular momentum.
So it's about time
to really do it.
We haven't done it yet.
But now the part that
we have to do now,
it's kind of a nice exercise.
And it's fun.
Now, there's one problem
in the homework set
that sort of uses
this kind of thing.
And I will suggest there to
Will and Aram that tomorrow,
they spend some time discussing
it and helping you with it.
The last problem
in the homework set
would've been better if you
had a little more time for it
and you had more time to
digest what I'm doing today.
But nevertheless,
go to recitation,
learn more about the problem.
It will not be all
that difficult.
OK, so we're trying
now to finally form
another basis of states.
We had these six states.
And we're going to
try to organize them
in a better way-- as eigenstates
of the total angular momentum L
plus S. So I'm going to
write them here in this way.
Here is one of the
states of this L equals
1 electron, the 1, 1
coupled to the 1/2, 1/2.
Here are two more states- 1, 0,
1/2, 1/2, 1, 1, 1/2, minus 1/2,
so the 1, 0 with the top,
the 1, 1 with the bottom.
Here are two more
states-- 1, 0 with 1/2,
minus 1/2 and 1,
minus 1 with 1/2, 1/2.
And here is the last state--
1, minus 1 with 1/2, minus 1.
These are our six states.
And I've organized them
in a nice way actually.
I've organized
them in such a way
that you can read what is
the value of Jz over h bar.
Remember, Jz is 1
over h bar Lz plus Sz.
So what is it?
These are, I claim,
eigenstates of Jz.
Why?
Because let's act on them.
Suppose I act with
Jz on this state.
The Lz comes here and says, 1.
The Sz comes here and says, 1/2.
So the sum of them give you
Jz over h bar equal to 3/2.
And that's why I organized
these states in such a way
that these second things add up
to the same value-- 0 and 1/2,
1 and minus 1/2.
So if you act with
Jz on this state,
it's an eigenstate with Jz.
Here, 0 contribution, here 1/2.
So this is with plus 1/2.
Here, you have 0 and minus 1/2,
minus 1, and that is minus 1/2.
And here you have minus 3/2.
OK, questions.
We've written the states.
And I'm evaluating the total z
component of angular momentum.
And these two states
are like that.
So what does our theorem
guarantee for us?
Our theorem guarantees that we
have-- in this tensor product,
there is an algebra of angular
momentum of the Jz operators.
And the states have to
fall into representations
of those operators.
So you must have angular
momentum multiplets.
So at this moment,
you can figure out
what angular momentum you're
going to get for the result.
Here we obtained a
maximum Jz of 3/2.
So we must get a J
equals 3/2 multiplet.
Because a J equaling
3/2 multiplets
has Jz 3/2, 1/2,
minus 1/2, and 0.
So actually, this state must be
the top state of the multiplet.
This state must be the bottom
state of the multiplet.
I don't know which one is the
middle state of the multiplet
and which one is here.
But we have four states
here, four states.
So one linear combination
of these two states
must be, then, that Jz equals
1/2 state of the multiplet.
And one inner combination
of these two states
must be that Jz equals minus
1/2 state of the multiplet.
Which one is it?
I don't know.
But we can figure it out.
We'll figure it out in a second.
Once you get this
J 3/2 multiplet,
there will be one linear
combination here left over
and one linear combination
here left over.
Those are two state, one with
Jz plus 1/2 and one with Jz
equals minus 1/2.
So you also get a J
equals 1/2 multiplet.
So the whole tensor
product of six
states-- it was the
tensor product of a spin 1
with a spin 1/2.
So we write it like this.
The tensor product of a
spin 1 with a spin 1/2
will give you a total
spin 3/2 plus total spin
1/2-- funny formula.
Here is the tensor
product, the tensor
product of these three
states with these two states.
This can be written as 3
times 2 is equal to 4 plus 2
in terms of number of states.
The tensor product of
this spin 1 and spin 1/2
gives you a spin 3/2
multiplet with four states
and a spin 1/2 multiplet
with two states.
So how do you calculate what
are the states themselves?
So the states themselves
are the following.
All right, here I have them.
I claim that the J
equals 3/2 states,
m equals 3/2 states, the
top state of that multiplet
can only be the state here,
the 1, 1 tensor 1/2, 1/2.
And there's no way any other
state can be put on the right.
Because there's no other
state with total z component
of angular momentum equals 3/2.
So that must be the state.
Similarly, the J
equals 3/2, m equals
minus 3/2 state must be the
bottom one-- 1, minus 1, 1/2,
minus 1/2.
The one that we
wish to figure out
is the next state here, which is
the J equals 3/2, m equals 1/2.
It's a linear
combination of these two.
But which one?
That is kind of the last
thing we want to do.
Because it will pretty much
solve the rest of the problem.
So how do we solve for this?
Well, we had this
basic relation that we
know how to lower or raise
states of angular momentum--
m times m plus/minus 1 J--
I should have written it
J plus/minus Jm equals
h bar square root.
More space for everybody
to see this-- J times
J plus 1 minus m
times m plus/minus 1.
Close the square
root-- Jm plus/minus 1.
So what I should try to
do is lower this state,
try to find this state
by acting with J minus.
So let me try to
lower the state, so
J minus on this state, on
J equals 3/2, m equals 3/2.
I can go to that formula and
write it as h bar square root.
J is 3/2, so 3/2 times
5/2 minus m, which is 3/2,
times m minus 1, 1/2.
We're doing the minus--
times the state 3/2, 1/2.
So the state we want is here.
And it's obtained by
doing J minus on that.
But we want the number here.
So that's why I did
all these square roots.
And that just gives h bar
square root of 3, 3/2, 1/2.
Well, that still doesn't
calculate it for me.
But it comes very close.
So you have it there.
Now I want to do this but
using the right hand side.
So look at the right hand side.
We want to do J minus, but
on 1, 1 tensor 1/2, 1/2.
So I applied J minus
to the left hand side.
Now we have to apply J minus
to the right hand side.
But J minus is L minus plus S
minus on 1, 1 tensor 1/2, 1/2.
When this acts, it
acts on the first.
So you get L minus on
1, 1 tensor 1/2, 1/2.
And in the second term,
you get plus 1, 1 tensor S
minus on 1/2, 1/2.
Now, what is L minus on 1, 1?
You can use the same formula.
It's 1, 1.
And it's an angular momentum.
So it just goes on and
gives you h bar square
root of 1 times 2
minus 1 times 0.
1, 0-- it lowers
it-- times 1/2, 1/2.
Let me go here-- plus 1, 1.
And what is S minus on this?
Use the formula
with J equals 1/2.
So this is h bar square root of
1/2 times 3/2 minus 1/2 times
minus 1/2 times 1/2 minus 1/2.
Whew-- well not too difficult.
But this gives you h over square
root of 2, 1, 0 tensor 1/2,
1/2 plus just h bar.
This whole thing is 1-- 1,
1 tensor 1/2, minus 1/2.
OK, stop a second to
see what's happened.
We had this equality.
And we acted with J minus.
Acting on the left,
it gives us a number
times the state we want.
Acting on the
right, we got this.
So actually, equating this
to that, or left hand side
to right hand side, we finally
found the state 3/2, 1/2.
So the state 3/2,
1/2 is as follows.
3/2, 1/2 is-- you must
divide by that square root.
So you get the square
root of 3 down.
The h bars cancel.
So here it is, a very nice
little formula-- 2 over 3,
1, 0 tensor 1/2, 1/2 plus
1 over square root of 3,
1, 1 tensor 1/2, minus 1/2.
So we have the top
state of the multiplet.
We have the next state
of the multiplet.
We have-- I'm sorry, the
top state of the multiplet
was this.
You have the bottom
state of the multiplet,
the middle state
of the multiplet.
What you're missing is the
bottom and the middle term.
And this one can be
obtained in many ways.
One way would be to
raise this state.
The minus 3/2 could
be raised by one unit
and do exactly the same thing.
Well, the result is square root
of 2 over 3, 1, 0 tensor 1/2,
minus 1/2 plus 1 over
square root of 3.
That square root of 2
doesn't look right to me now.
I must have copied it wrong.
It's 1 over square root of
3-- 1 over square root of 3,
1, minus 1 tensor 1/2, 1/2.
So you've built that
whole multiplet.
And this state, as we said,
was a linear combination
of the two possible states.
This 3 minus 1/2 was
a linear combination
of these two possible states.
So the other states
that are left over,
the other linear
combinations, form
the J equals 1/2 multiplet.
So basically, every state must
be orthogonal to each other.
So the other state, the 1/2, 1/2
and the 1/2, minus 1/2 of the J
equals 1/2 multiplet must
be this orthogonal to this.
And this must be
orthogonal to that.
So those formulas are easily
found by orthogonality.
So I'll conclude by
writing them-- minus 1
over square root of
3, 1, 0, 1/2, 1/2
plus the square root of 2
over 3, 1, 1, 1/2, minus 1/2.
And here, you get 1 over
square root of 3, 1, 0, 1/2,
minus 1/2 minus 2 over
square root of 3, 1, minus 1
tensor 1/2, 1/2.
So lots of terms, a little
hard to read-- I apologize.
Now, the punchline here is
that you've found these states.
And the claim is
that these are states
in which L dot S is diagonal.
And it's kind of obvious
that that should be the case.
Because what was L dot S?
So one last formula--
L dot S equals
1/2 of J squared minus L
squared minus S squared.
Now, in terms of
eigenvalues, this
is 1/2 h squared J times
J plus 1 minus L times L
plus 1 minus S times S plus 1.
Now, all the states
that we built
have definite
values of J squared,
definite values of S squared.
Because L was 1.
And S is 1/2.
So here you go h squared over 2
J times J plus 1 minus 1 times
2 is 2 minus 1/2
times 3/2 is 3/4.
And that's the whole story.
The whole story in a sense
has been summarized by this.
We have four states
with J equals 3/2
and two states
with J equals 1/2.
So these six states
that you have here--
split because of
this interaction
into four states that have
J equal to 3/2 and two
states that have J equal to 1/2.
And you plug the numbers here.
And that gives you the
amount of splitting.
So actually, this height
that this goes up here
is h squared over 2.
And this is minus h
squared by the time you
put the numbers J, 3/2, and 1/2.
So all our work was because
the Hamiltonian at the end
was simple in J squared.
And therefore, we
needed J multiplets.
J multiplets are the addition
of angular momentum multiplets.
In a sense, we don't have
to construct these things
if you don't want to calculate
very explicit details.
Once you have that,
you have everything.
This product of angular
momentum 1, angular momentum 1/2
gave you total
angular momentum 3/2
and 1/2-- four
states, two states.
So four states split one way,
two states split the other way,
and that's the end of the story.
So more of this in recitation
and more of this all
of next week.
We'll see you then.